[Musique]
ago propres au groupe roggo pro tu me
plaît je viens vous parler aujourd'hui
de quoi de la nouvelle caméra d'action
gôpô là ironise black qui
monde d'un grade encore on n'a plus le
monde un nouveau processeur c'est le gp2
savoir que le gp un combat d'avants est
arrivé avec l'aéro 6 blacc selah heroes
6 black capela merci l'aéro 6 black qui
est arrivé en 2010 est donc là on a un
nouveau proche permet d'aller plus loin
avec un peu plus de choses mais avant
d'ouvrir sa caméra y'a un truc qui est
vachement important c'est que vos
promenades il ya quelques temps tient
monsieur grenat ont peux pas t'en menez
à droite à gauche par des événements
tout un petit peu dingo cette année mais
on donne la possibilité et bien de faire
ce que tu veux donc est-ce qu'un truc
qui fait plaisir et puis on a eu le
meilleur 6 go pro je leur ai dit ok ya
peu que des jeunes aient fait c'est de
faire du saut en parachute j'ai pas
quelle idée j'ai eu donc voilà on va
commencer par regarder ce que ça dit je
peux vous le dire pas fait le malin
et c'est là gros pro combien ça nettoie
contre les matricules être là
immatriculations havrais était vraiment
super white
un bruit qui voit le l'éclairage
[Musique]
moi
je pense que j'ai encore une grosse
dessus du mcc a peur
alors raconte ses dunks ce que tu as
vécu chaque mois merci voilà c'est
dingue vois toi j'ai la bouche pâteuse
l'écrou je me faisais dessus mais
incroyable c'est incroyable vraiment on
est bien là haut quand même assez calme
mais là le le saut quand tu tombes
mais l'opposition on a volé on a
traversé des petits nuages c'était super
je me suis fait dessus je me change m le
fait qu'ils font est
faite de caisses
3500 m tu jets dans le ville tu espères
rester en vie ce qui globalement ne
paraît pas gagner sur le moment est en
fait le truc était absolument incroyable
c'est cette sensation de chute de pure
chute complètement libre qu'est ce que
je ferais pas pour vous montrer des
choses absolument incroyable qu'est ce
que je ferais pas elle touche 3 qui met
plus je retiens vraiment complètement
dingue c'est le fait en fait de se dire
je je suis passé à travers un nuage donc
je vous le confirme j'ai été déçu
pays des bisounours n'existe pas on ne
peut pas marcher sur un nuage ce n'est
pas du coton voilà ça c'est la boîte de
la nouvelle caméra gopro 0,10 black qui
vont prendre caméras il y en a des
tonnes ça c'est la 7 l'évolution majeure
s'est fait d'enlever cette coco tour qui
était hyper galère dès qu'on voulait
changer sa carte est arrivé l'a8 blacks
où vous avez vos petits patins qui sont
là et qui sont plutôt bien le problème
assez qu'on n'y voyait rien lorsqu'on se
filmer est arrivé avec la nomme black et
bien un écran à l'avant mais le problème
de la nef blacks c'est que des fois on
manquait un peu de performance pour
monter plus haut dans les tours et faire
plus de choses arrive donc l'a10 blake
qui a le grand écran les petits patins
en dessous et surtout un nouveau
processeur c'est le gp2 alors avant vous
montrer les résultats voici la boîte et
voici ce qu'on va dire trouvaient à
l'intérieur vous avez ce qu'il faut pour
venir le posez là dessus venir filmer
facilement c'est un petit bras articulé
qui fait office de pied pour ça c'est
plutôt sympa un petit adhésif pour venir
à l'attacher sur casque si vous le
voulez on a d'adhésifs légèrement
incurvé ça c'est pour venir poser
directement sur votre petit accessoire
qui est là de quoi le connecter
directement en usb ou usb c'est usb à un
ordinateur hockey et puis voilà on a
fait le tour que vous avez la caméra qui
est à l'intérieur et vous avez une
deuxième batterie qui inclut donc ça
s'est très très bien ici j'ai choisi un
des pires endroits de paris pour venir
tester une stabilisation c'est sur les
pavés on en bord de seine le problème
c'est que ça bouge tout le temps comme
ça le vélo est comme ça et j'ai les
docks qui claque comme ça c'est hyper
galère ça bouge tous les côtés
[Musique]
5 3 4 images par seconde grâce au
nouveau proche le gp2 ensuite je suis
passé en 4k images par seconde
en large avec l'hyper snus au max c'est
le booste ça donne vraiment complètement
stabilisé alors on voit quand même que
par moments ça bouge un peu mais
regardez ça qu'on est là on est là
dessus on est sur du pavé nouveaux
processeurs plus de performances de plus
de puissance ça vient apporter plus de
fluidité premier truc intéressant c'est
lorsque vous appuyez sur le bouton pour
venir enregistrer sa lance directement
on a aussi plus de fluidité lorsqu'on
vient naviguer derrière c'est un peu
plus mou sur l'écran avant alors on soit
a toujours très très bien il ya un côté
très floue lorsque je nova comme ça donc
j'espère que là je suis bien mais parce
que je ne me rends pas vraiment compte
ça c'est encore un des points à venir
améliorer la qualité de l'écran vous
avez devant par contre on a un regret
des la qualité en terme de capacité de
calcul donc on va plus loin en termes de
résolution ont fait de l'a5 d'un but
trois cas à 60 images par seconde contre
30 images par seconde sur l'a54 la
génération précédente blacks ont fait la
4k à 120 images par seconde contre la 4k
à 60 l'année dernière et ont fait de la
2,7 cap à 240 images par seconde entre
eux s'en va l'année dernière
[Musique]
y a pas de changement là dessus au
niveau de la partie photo par contre
vous pouvez extraire des images on 16,6
millions de pixels à partir d'une vidéo
en cinq cas format 4/3
[Musique]
nouveauté qui est intéressant c'est
l'hyper smooth ajouté
c'est la stabilisation en fait un
stabilisation logiciel isabelle les
personnes me suis 3.0 là en arrière
c'est l'hyper smooth 4.0 qu'on a cette
année on l'est toujours plus stabilisée
mais ça fait c'est derrière la marque un
peu hypersonique qui est vraiment
marketing ce qu'il faut venir retenir
c'est que comme vous avez un proche qui
est plus performant qu'à dire c'est
complètement normal
d'avoir une meilleure stabilisation sont
pas il faut changer de crémerie y aura
problème en fait ils appellent ça hyper
trousses
quatre points 1 0 mais en fait c'est
juste une évolution de ce qu'ils avaient
avant d'un point de vue logiciel jégo
pris la mer donner des dix nominations
un petit peu marchetti c'est un produit
qui perd bien marketé ça me paraît
normal j'ai noté un autre truc qui me
plaît vachement par rapport à l'année
dernière c'est tout le traitement des
peaux prouve qu vachement plus bon
acteur de poids qui est beaucoup plus
naturelle et c'est marrant parce que je
m'étais pas vraiment rendu compte
l'année dernière et là je me rends
vraiment propres aux parents en fait ce
que j'ai encore la gopro heroes neuf
blacks et à 10 black est vrai gars qui
est fait il ya aussi un autre truc qui
est assez intéressant qui viennent de
sortir cet objectif il a été améliorée
objectif atteint change interchangeables
vous pouvez mettre des petits modules
alors ici j'ai pas de module vous
pourriez venir changer votre module
émettre un module max et à différents
modules vous avez un avec un moniteur
pour avoir un média kit avec un micro
enfin bref pas mal de petites solutions
est-ce qu'il coule c'est que le
l'objectif qui vous ont mis là il est
plus résistant aux rayures il a évité
tout ce qui va être reflets un petit peu
fantôme il va éviter plein de petites
imperfections vous pourriez avoir à
l'image il améliore également ici au
niveau de leurs sous traitants j'imagine
pour avoir des produits encore mieux
fini encore plus intéressant la limite
qu'on peut venir voir aussi par moments
c'est au niveau des hautes lumières sais
pas si vous l'avez vu dans la vidéo en
parachute même si dans l'ensemble ça
marche vachement bien il gère très bien
s'adapter à différents lumière en
fonction que je sois sous l'oeil de
l'avion ou pas donc ça c'est vachement
cool par contre par moments sur les
hautes lumières il encore un petit peu
de mal encore un petit truc à venir
améliorer ça va déjà mieux ça progresse
d'année en année mais il ya encore un
petit truc à venir chercher alors
oubliez pas content du tout petits
capteurs sont légaux peau on peut pas
non plus faire de la magie mais bon
c'est vrai que pour faire ce qui nous
sort déjà que tout petits capteurs dans
cette petite caméra qui coûtera 500
balles en france est énorme et il ya un
truc qui intéresse entre cas ils ont
bossé c'est de venir améliorer tout le
contenu qui est fait au niveau de la
plaque oui photo nuit vidéo nous ça
tombe bien on va ça leur a plu pour
minuit et on va regarder ce que ça dit
alors là on se met dans un actuel
c'est pas la nuit mais on fait un peu la
fesci et c'est très pratique pour bien
travailler
ce qui nous propose c'est d'avoir un
contenu qui fêtera
qui va être optimisée éviter qu'on ait
du bruit numérique meynard armé à face à
une réduction bruit en trois dimensions
après le gros point que vous avez en
plus avec baup rencontre va forcément
avec des concurrents c'est qu'ils ont
tout un ensemble de produits qui peuvent
venir s'interconnecter s'adapter ce soit
un accessoire pour venir tenir à la main
comme ça une espèce de perche que vous
aller me reposer sur le vélo que ce soit
10 km sur des casques dalle ces cadeaux
groupe est aussi très travaillants qui a
vraiment tout cet ensemble qui est super
super cool et un autre temps qui est
aussi intéressant c'est que je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez vous en avez parlé
une dernière lors de la présentation de
la neuve blake en 9 là qu'ils allaient
changer la batterie et une bataille
était plus grosse pas compatible avec la
wii black est là pour le coup ils ont
gardé la même batterie donc sept groupes
hommage à trouve vraiment couronnée par
une très très belle évolution avec le
processeur le gp2 apporte vraiment
quelque chose j'ai encore des choses à
venir améliorer que l'écran l'avant
avoir une meilleure définition se
retrouver avec un écran un peu tactile
et j'en sais rien mais c'est à dire
chercher de ce côté là la couleur il
vachement plus belle le traitement au
niveau des pots il ya encore pas mal
d'éléments d'amélioration mais par
rapport à ce qu'on a là je pars pas dire
que c'est un beau
bogaert si vous posez la question de
changer de go pro faire votre choix
entre tous les modèles ça vaut le coup
de mettre un peu plus d'argent pour
passer sur l'a10 blacks ont pas
forcément aller sur l'a9 black ou une 8
blague parce que ce qui est bien d'éclat
disent c'est comme vous avez sous vos
proches vous allez aller plus loin en
termes de calcul vous à l'heure des
images sont les plus fluides plus grand
pour l'expérience va être mieux ça va
s'allumer tout de suite dès que vous
avez besoin de vous appuyer sa part en
fait qu'à vachement de bénéfices ça
c'est un peu comme ce qu'on veut
vraiment vraiment intéressant au niveau
de l'expérience et légaux pour autre
élément qui est poule qui a été mis à
jour c'est le mode webcam sexy
intéressante les modes webcam c'est ce
qu'on avait l'année dernière ce que si
vous voulez faire par exemple vous
connecter sur un réseau social pour
venir faire du lac stream vous pouvez le
faire c'est du 1080p avec un champion de
130 degrés mais le truc qui est nouveau
cette année c'est qu'ils ont rajouté en
plus de ça c'est l'hyper smooth donc
pouvez vous connecter faire un live
partir marchés partent à vous balader en
face que vous avez c'est que vous avez
de la stabilisation donc ça vous évite
d'avoir à poser une webcam fixe voulait
faire un live en vous baladant je ne
sais où la caméra soit yacout 529 euros
99 du budget après une jolie bête est ce
un petit budget et là où ils sont malins
situe vous la vendre 100 euros moins
cher si vous prenez un abonnement chez
go pro à 429 points 99 en fait ce qu'ils
veulent c'est vous prenez la bonne et
ils vous poussent à prendre la bonne et
après vous avez un bundle sans
abonnement à 579 euros 99 et avec un
abonnement s'emballe moins cher vous ai
compris
479 euros 99 donc c'est tout ce que je
voulais vous dire aujourd'hui je dois
filer dans un endroit un peu secret pas
du tout à une agence récupérer des
produits qui vont être présentées d'ici
15 jours je crois pas encore vous en
parler je peux pas vous les montrer mais
je vous montrerai bientôt et croyez-moi
croyez moi sur parole ça va envoyer
devant ça c'est cool on va essayer de
passer en 2e on traversait voilà les
bisous à bientôt ciao